Hey folks, um, great to, great to see y'all,
uh, really excited to be here. My name's Russell
Kaplan, co-founder, president at Cognition,
and, uh, today we wanted to talk about, uh, just
building with agents and what we're seeing in real
world enterprises, uh, adopting
AI for software engineering, what's working,
what's not working, and, uh, sharing
some details.
Uh, before we get into it, I guess, can you raise your hand?
Have, has, uh,
if you've ever heard of Cognition or Devon
or Windsurf before.
Great. OK, basically, everyone, um, so for,
uh, for those who, who haven't heard of us, uh,
we are an AI software
engineering company, uh, an agent lab.
We started,
uh, almost 2 years ago
originally as a research lab
focused on long-term reasoning and
planning. Uh, we're lucky to work with many
of the largest, most sophisticated enterprises
in the world, uh, as well as thousands of companies
globally, um.
When we got started, it was really out of a,
a love of software engineering,
uh, and programming. Many of the folks on the
founding team are
competitive, uh, programmers by training.
I joke that Scott is the CEO
because he has the most gold medals on the team.
Uh, he's the most in the history of the United States.
Uh, he's actually still the coach for the US national
team on the side. Um, so it's a bunch of people who
really love to code
and, um,
we. Noticed
in the sort of end of 2023 early 2024
that AI has made lots
of progress in chat and
real-time interfaces, uh, but
reasoning was really falling behind and you couldn't really
give real world long
term end to end work to AI systems
and have this work actually well
so we started cognition originally as a reason. lab
focused on, uh, long term thinking,
planning in the context of
software engineering, um, and it's been a
really exciting journey so far.
Uh, we are now nearly 200 people
with several offices around the world. Uh, we've
raised about $700 million most recently at
a $10 billion evaluation,
uh, and we're deployed at, uh, a lot of great companies
including some of the folks in this room.
One thing we've seen
is that the ability
of AI to code well
has been increasing significantly
uh since the beginning of AI
products in software engineering.
And there's lots of different ways to measure this.
This is just one example. This is the
merge rate of
Devon pull requests. So every time
someone gives Devin, the AI software
engineer that we make,
um, a task to go do,
that task will result in a pull request, and it
will be automatically submitted.
Uh, and up for a human to review
and we, this, this rate at which these,
these, uh, requests are getting merged is, is steadily
increasing and it's doubled to, uh, almost 70%
over, over the last year, um, and these
workloads are, you know, these are not one
line fixes, these are kind of
4 to 8 hour typically like
junior engineering to mid-level
engineering scope tasks on real
world, uh, production code
base, but what we've
seen is that in the kind of broader ecosystem.
Most teams in industry are
significantly uh behind
using the full potential
of AI for software
engineering
and today we wanna talk about why we think that is
what are the important ingredients to change that
and where are some examples of this already working really well
at scale,
um. To put this in perspective,
I think you could really view the
progress of AI tooling and software engineering
over sort of three waves,
uh, and the first was really like, uh,
the kind of co-pilot tab
completion style way where you're in
your editor, you're writing some code, and you get a prediction.
What, uh, you know, what code should come next.
It's a very real-time synchronous experience,
uh, for a sort of line by line, uh,
programming or function by function programming, and this
already was an amazing product experience.
GitHub copilot really led the way in this, and it's
been used by many, many folks all around
the world for real productivity gains.
The second wave has been
full AI IDEs, so
no longer just tab completion, but
a completely sort of a new
development environment built for the ground
up for leveraging AI
at every turn, both for tab completion
but also for chat, for code-based understanding,
uh, for local synchronous agents working
with you for documentation, uh,
for all of the sort of ways you could get leverage
from AI at every turn,
um. The third wave,
which is really the most recent, is
the full AI software
engineer. So this is more co-worker
than co-pilot, something you delegate
complete units of work to, maybe going directly
from a ticket
to a full finished pull request,
um, and
what we've seen is that across these different ways of
working. Uh,
these types of systems are already having
meaningful real impact at scale
in the enterprise, um, as some
examples from our customer customer base,
one top five global bank measured a roughly
16x faster migration timeline
for 40,000 legacy ETL framework
files going,
uh, to Java.
Another example is test coverage automation
and improvement, top 3 global retailer
measuring at least 90% of system coverage,
uh, system testing coverage after
using AI to improve both unit
and end to end integration tests
written automatically by AI coding agents.
Um, a third example is, um.
Documentation and indexing and
code-based understanding,
um, one of the largest banks in the world has
more than 300,000 repositories
documented automatically
by cognition, uh, and this
includes very legacy systems as well as very
modern systems,
um. And we're also seeing this
in Project Velocity, so a Fortune
5 healthcare, uh, company that's getting
a multi-X improvement in product velocity
as measured from the beginning of when
you start up the project to when it's going
to ship, how you would have done it the old way, how
you are doing it the new way.
Um, and so some of these companies are doing really
well, basically deploying these systems and getting
real value to them at scale,
and we've worked with many such companies now, more than 1000
enterprises around the world,
and we've noticed a few patterns
that are common among the folks
who are the most successful at deploying
and using
AI. So we're gonna talk about what these
patterns are from the product and rollout
perspective
and what they are from the change management perspective
as well.
So first, the deployment patterns.
The first is a recognition that
different forms of AI for software engineering
have different fundamental technical
trade-offs, and so multiple modes
of using AI are actually quite important, both
the real-time synchronous assistant
type workflow and also the asynchronous,
more autonomous delegation type
workflow.
The second is that
understanding the existing code and context
inside a company is really critical
to getting true real world
value. Um, it's, it's actually relatively
straightforward at this point to, to build an AI system
that can kind of prototype a new
website or or a product from scratch. But
to work within the context of an existing
business that has its own requirements,
proprietary frameworks,
um, historical decisions that have lots
of context that maybe no one person even has,
um, and maybe regulatory or
process requirements that have to get followed for code
to be successful,
it's a lot more complicated and we've learned
a lot about how to do that well and not well
and why that's really important for, um,
driving real world results.
The third is how do you start to use these
AI tools
to help improve velocity
across the entire
software development life cycle.
Writing code is one part of that, but it's
only one part of that, and the next generation
of productivity gains to go from the 10,
20% to the multi-X all involve
automating entire swaths of the STLC
for specific workloads, not just the
writing code.
So a little bit more on this, this first point
of multiple modes of working with
AI software engineering tooling.
Uh,
we're finding that it's relatively
easier to adopt synchronous
real-time AI assistance.
Um, developers are already very comfortable in
their IDE.
And this paradigm of working in flow
state writing code has been the way we write
code for a long time, right, from, from
Vim to modern, uh, modern IDEs
to now agentic IDEs, you're in flow
state in your editor writing code just
now with leverage and speed up from AI
systems, um, at cognition we make
Windsurf, the, um, agentic IDE.
It's designed to keep engineers in flow
state as they're programming,
and there's a fundamentally 1 to 1
relationship between each engineer
and their real-time AI
assistants,
so immediate speed ups
very useful for, uh, challenging
creative work where you have to be working
hand in hand with AI to deliver outcomes.
Increasingly, a lot of software
engineering has become
addressable by a completely different form factor.
Which is the asynchronous autonomous
delegation style model, um, you have an AI
engineer that's actually doing the full work end to end
from the details of the scoping to the implementation
to the testing to the review
to, um, the complete proposal of
a, of a pull request,
um, and this has different technical trade-offs, so it's
asynchronous instead of synchronous. Uh, it's gonna
take longer,
but you can kick off many of these in parallel,
um, and because it's
asynchronous,
uh, you can tolerate
much longer latency. In exchange for higher degrees
of correctness and completeness,
um, and there's certain workloads that are
extremely appealing for this type of software
engineering automation. There are others where it's frankly,
um, too hard and the systems are not yet
good enough to do this reliably.
Our heuristic that we found with Devon
is that tasks that are roughly half
day to 1 day's worth of work
for a junior to mid-level engineer are
about the right level of difficulty to
delegate to any one Devon session.
And for things that are more complicated,
um, the human engineer is responsible for
really breaking up that project into discrete
components and then you can delegate it to
an entire team of AI agents
and in this way the role of being an
individual software engineer
is changing a little bit to becoming
kind of. Like a tech lead manager where you're still writing
some code yourself but you're also increasingly delegating
work to your team of async AI agents
and that's a fundamentally different work flow for
a lot of folks, uh, and it means that to roll this
out successfully there's a kind of a learning
curve and an organizational change element
that's really important as well.
Um, so how are we actually building towards this, uh,
uh, with Windsurf we're very, very focused
on speed, keeping people in flow
state. One of the first observations we
found is that modern models make tough
trade-offs between intelligence and
speed. Uh, you can use frontier models,
uh, relatively slow token per second rate, and
you're kind of waiting for a response from your chat
or from code suggestions, and those
few seconds really add up. They can interrupt
your flow state. They can get you distracted.
It's sort of the modern day equivalent of I'm waiting for
my code to compile.
Um, uh, on the other hand, historically,
very, very fast models have had to make severe
intelligence trade-offs to make them run quickly.
Um, we've done a lot of work
building in-house RL models at cognition
to try to balance the best of both
worlds, and we recently released a new
model family called Suite 1.5
which is achieving roughly
frontier class performance on
the, the sort of state of the art industry benchmark
for. Agentic coding which is called Swi Bench
Pro so you can see, uh, in this,
in this evaluation, the x axis here
is the score on this benchmark on a
standardized harness, and it's a little bit
behind Sonnet 4.5. It's a little bit
ahead of GPT, uh, of
the sort of frontier open AI model
series, um,
so it's, it's not outperforming, but it's
not underperforming on quality.
On the other hand, on speed, it's in
order of magnitude faster, so this is served at roughly
950 tokens per second,
about 10 times faster than kind of other alternatives,
and the way we made that possible was by building a lot of
infrastructure and modeling in-house and
partnering with Cerebris, the maker of wafer scale
chips, uh, which collectively allow us to
serve these models extremely quickly.
And because of that we get an end to end
product experience where
you can get results nearly as fast as you
can think them and we found that this is the key
for staying in flow state as you're using
AI tools yourself, uh, to,
to create code.
Uh, on the other end of the spectrum you have
the asynchronous delegation workflow,
um, and so what's the best practice for making that
really work inside a company.
I'll talk through an example of a migration
project because this is one type of workload migrations,
modernizations, refactors that are
especially well suited to the Devon
form factor.
Typically a large migration project, um,
first has to be architected by a
senior, uh, engineer, uh,
from, uh, from the existing team who has
context on everything going on in the organization and
can make the right technical trade-offs of
what's the desired end state we're trying to get to
and then also what's our incremental path there.
That part of the process is not going away
right now.
We need humans to architect the desired
end state of these migrations.
But once you've done that architecting work and
you've kind of broken up how should this get
done, you end up with lots of individual
pieces. Maybe they're tickets in an Epic and Jira, uh,
maybe they're specific, uh, ETL pipelines
in a broader overall ecosystem. Maybe they're
files or libraries in a monolithic repository
where you have to do a major version upgrade,
uh, to a, to a, to a modern, uh, a modern version.
Once you have those individual pieces,
that's where you can start to really get the benefit of
delegation to autonomous AI software
agents
and so,
uh, the workflow we found works best with Devon
is after these pieces are broken up,
you can delegate one piece to Devon
and Devin will
work on the specific execution
and implementation of that narrow
change. And because it's broken up,
that change is actually digestible and doable
entirely end to end again, not just the writing of the code,
but any further gathering of specific requirements
that need to be accounted for, the writing and the
planning of the code, uh, and then the testing
of the code.
We found that uh since day one when we launched 7,
every session runs in an isolated virtual
machine which in addition to having a code editor
also has a command line. It has a web
browser. It's a full replica of the
human development environment of the companies
we work with and because of that, after
the code is written,
the code can be tested whether it's using existing tests
that are. Exists inside the organization or
having Devin write new tests to check its own work
even if there are no tests we found, you know, Devin can
do pixel level interaction on these
systems so that you end up understanding
does uh does this new website actually work
when you click with it does this new desktop app actually work
and the result of that might be, hey, it didn't work on the
first try,
but that's OK.
Because this is an asynchronous form factor,
so Devon can notice that and then fix its
code, test itself again, fix its code, test
itself again
until it gets to a state where it's very confident the
change is correct.
Only when you're at that point is that change served
up as a ready to review pull
request for the human software engineer,
and this can be paralyzed across many,
many projects, uh, many, many components of the overall
larger project in parallel.
So this is the workflow that we're seeing for
really deploying asynchronous autonomous
software engineering agents at scale in a way
that drives really measurable impact.
If you imagine the day in the life of a software
engineer who's fully embraced this modern
suite of AI tooling,
you might start out in the morning, the beginning of your
day, planning out the work
that needs to get done,
uh, delegating some tasks to your
asynchronous agents, scoping some
things in more detail so that they're sufficiently broken
up, and firing off a lot of these things
in parallel.
Once those things are working, uh,
then you can sit down and actually start coding yourself,
uh, in Windsurf or whatever tool you choose
to have that flow state quick interaction
with systems, especially for the more complicated,
complex projects or projects that aren't
really scoped like complex greenfield development
where you're kind of building, you're, you're discovering and
you're building as you go,
but critically in this future mode of working.
If you don't also have those asynchronous agents
working in the background,
you're, you're not being very efficient with your time
because you could have also at the same time been delegating
this work to others.
It actually reminds me of my time previously
where I was at Tesla on the autopilot team
as a kind of computer vision scientist working on
training neural networks for the self-driving system.
And we had a rule of thumb internally that
you can never
go to bed with the GPUs idling
because you're wasting tremendous amounts of compute,
uh, where the models could be working while you're sleeping,
and I think what we're gonna see in software engineering is kind of the
same type of concept applied, uh,
to working with asynchronous agents as well. The
agent should be working while you are working too.
And then it's time to check that work. Maybe after
your lunch break you look at the PRs, ready
to review. You leave some feedback. Some are ready to merge,
and then you can go back to your own coding.
Uh, your own approvals, your own merging, and
then the delegation again.
This is the workflow of the most productive software
engineers that we see in the organizations
we work with,
the mix of synchronous and asynchronous
AI collaboration.
One important lesson is that you have to
really pick a side, synchronous or asynchronous,
for any given workflow,
and the worst experience is what we call
the semi- async valley of death.
It's, uh, those tasks that maybe take
a few minutes, 1 minute, 2 minutes. It's enough
time that you can't stay in flow state anymore,
uh, but it's not so much time that you're getting the full
benefits of
independent autonomy.
Um, it's. OK to make things run for a very long
time if by the time those changes come back
we're confident that they're likely to be correct, it's
also OK to work closely hand in hand with AI
systems yourself.
The semi- async valley of death is what you need to
avoid, and we've tried to build our product suite,
really embracing that, making different technical trade-offs for
the different surfaces that we work with.
The second pattern
is that
it's really important for agents to
understand the existing code.
This is, I think, the single biggest
rate limiter
on overall software engineering productivity,
certainly for AI.
I would argue probably for humans as well.
This is one of the central challenges of scaling engineering
velocity as the organization gets larger.
No one person. Has all the context of what's
going on. There are decisions that are made. There's historical
details that are unclear, and
a huge amount of time is spent gathering that
context, groing new systems,
onboarding and ramping as a new engineer to a new
part of the code base. Um, and the same is
true of AI.
In AI, this, the issue is sufficiently
exac exacerbated
because models have limited context windows.
And so if you're just working with an LLM
as opposed to an agent, you'll run
into this issue
extremely quickly. Even
most agents today
very clearly struggle with
working on larger, more complex systems,
brownfield development
because of this fundamental lack of understanding,
this lack of context.
And we recognized that this was a central challenge to building
agents that provide useful
real world work.
And so earlier in 2025, uh,
we released a product called Deep Wiki,
which is an
indexing and understanding of
the macro scale context of
your code base.
Uh, this product surface is deployed at
very, very large scale, for example, tens to hundreds
of millions of lines of code,
um, and these are, these are repositories
that could be.
Thrown into an LLM
and use this context,
we built this product experience originally
entirely as an internal tool
for Deb so that Devon could have
macro context on the code
base it was working on
as it was working.
And we found that this tool was so useful
for improving
Devon and later Windsurf's performance
that the human engineers on our team got jealous
and said we, we, we want to use this too,
and we eventually decided let's, let's put a front end
around it, uh, and make it available
and that's what became. DeepWiki and today DeepWiki
is available globally free uh for
all open source repos. You can change
the GitHub URL of any repo to
DeepWiki.com instead of GitHub.com
and try it yourself
and it's also available for all the private code bases
we work with across our customers.
And I wanna show you an example
of what this looks like in practice,
um, so here.
I have a video of pulling
up a very fun
repo with lots of tricky contexts,
the original Apollo 11 source
code. So this is uh Apollo 11
assembly code that was written many
years ago for the Apollo missions,
and Deep Wiki has gone and indexed this
code and provided what's essentially a living
breathing confluence page for the repo
where, um,
modules, architecture diagrams,
macro context is all documented automatically.
And we look at the code,
not just the comments, because we found that
the comments often drift from the code
and are an unreliable source of truth in a large scale
organization. You can look into specific modules,
get more detail, um, see the data flow,
the, um, the interface contracts,
and, uh, really go into a lot of detail.
But sometimes you actually want to ask questions about the codebase
itself and so we built that experience as well.
Uh, here we're asking where is the liftoff sequence
for the Apollo mission actually implemented.
And uh DeepWK has gone through the
code. It's found the specific key
component that's most relevant. It's the P11
component,
uh, and it walks through how liftoff detection works
line by line
with the relevant assembly on the side
as well. So you can validate the work of the AI
again in this like synchronous flow state experience.
And here you can see in even more
detail what we call a code map.
Code map is a human interpretable
representation
of what would otherwise be considered very
complex control flow in code to
follow along.
So you can see on the left, uh, we have
a prose summary of the overall liftoff
sequence
and then this indented nested, uh,
kind of like pseudo code documentation
for how the different components of this process
work. On the right you see
the assembly.
And these are mapped together.
This code map experience, it lets engineers
get much better detailed understanding
of how these tools fit together.
And this is live for all engineers in
Windsurf today. You can use this interface
to really understand whether it's a legacy
system, a modern system, or a complex interconnected
set of code bases,
how these control flows fit together
at different levels of resolution.
Ultimately, scaling code-based understanding
is what affects agent productivity,
but it also affects human productivity.
Um, we found that when folks are
planning
new software engineering projects.
A huge amount of the time spent in the planning
process is gathering this context,
and our customers who have deployed this at scale have
found that this capability is a very
meaningful contributor to
increased planning velocity.
Um, this is an example from ITA
which we'll talk more about later. After rolling
out, uh, documentation through Deep
Wiki to their existing repositories, they
measure on average it would take literally 10
times as fast to plan the infrastructure
architectural work of new projects rather than
engineer going off doing research, writing some Google Docs,
scoping out, here's all the things we need to do.
It starts with an interactive deep wiki sessions where the architecture
diagrams are already there.
They're validated by the engineer by looking at
the source code and double checking.
Um, and the task and scoped
and broken down
through this search and natural language
interface.
What's the 3rd pattern?
The 3rd pattern, arguably the most important,
is that the productivity gains of the future
are going to come
from the usage of AI coding
across the entire software development life cycle.
It's no longer enough
to just help with writing code.
There's lots of different estimates on this.
Um, Microsoft and software.com
have both estimated around 20%
or less
of human software engineering time in an
enterprise is spent
actually writing code.
The rest is everything else
understanding the existing code, planning what code we
should write, collaborating with colleagues to make sure
that those specs are accurate,
writing the code, but then reviewing the code,
testing the code,
running QA through the code,
fixing things that are found,
repeating this process until a change is actually
ready to ship.
And if you think about how we've designed the SDLC.
Most of it has been designed assuming
that the code writing part
is the scarce resource. This is why we
do planning. This is why we do project
management the way we do it. It's that we couldn't waste engineers'
time writing code that's not useful
because that's such an expensive, uh, constrained
resource. But what we're finding is that
when you have this abundance of
code writing happening from AI,
everything else becomes much more of a bottleneck.
Much more of a bottleneck and so to get the next
level of productivity gains you have to figure out how do we optimize
the end to end system, not just one
component
of the system.
Um, as an example of each
step here, on, on the code writing side,
uh, one of our customers, New Bank,
they had a problem to migrate, uh, eight year
old multi-million line ETL monolith.
Uh, this bank had grown very quickly.
They needed help decomposing
their monolithic ETL repository into
separate modules so that each line of business
could have independent control of their work without
breaking changes for other lines of business.
This was originally scoped to be an 18 month
engineering effort requiring some repetitive refactoring
work distributed across more than 1000
engineers. Ultimately,
this type of workload fits extremely
well in the async delegation paradigm
we talked about previously.
And they were able to do this project, um,
with
1/8 of the human time
at a 20x cost saving by delegating
the work to them. The human work doesn't go
away. You still have to scope out what's the desired end
state, um, of the changes. They
should still be reviewed by a human before they're approved.
But if you amortize the human time spent taken,
uh, to review each change and then for some fraction
of the time maybe making modifications or
edits,
on average this was around 1/8 of the time
it took to do it the manual way.
And so the larger the migration that we factor the
project, the bigger these gains can be in
absolute terms.
Once you've written the code, you need to review the code,
uh, and AI is also able to help
with code review. Now,
um, what we found is that increasingly
as a paradigm
organizations are asking AI to take the first
pass at reviewing the code
that's written for correctness,
conformance with organizational best practices,
potential security vulnerabilities, and other
issues, and only then does
it make sense to spend the more precious
human time
looking at things on top.
This can all be configured via API.
Um, this is an example
of a pull request that was reviewed
by Devon,
uh, where a sequel, uh, a SQL injection vulnerability
was discovered automatically. You can configure
Devon, you can configure any, you know, uh, asynchronous
agent experience
to work well within the existing SCLC
at the review layer too.
But let's be real, there are some dedicated tools
for things like
static analysis of security tools.
We don't have to throw AI at everything. In
fact, when there's a deterministic way to do something, we
strongly recommend do it the deterministic way
instead. Only when that doesn't work
should you use AI at all.
But what we found is that the deterministic
way plus AI leverage and automation
is often the best possible solution.
Uh, for example, um, many leading static
analysis tools like SonarCube,
uh, Fortify, Vericode, Sneak, you know, they
produce huge volumes of findings that enterprise
scale can add up to lots of engineering
toil to triage and remediate.
Um, once these, uh, once
these existing static analysis tools are connected
to autonomous asynchronous AI agents,
you get this multiplicative speed up where
engineers only have to look at the alerts that
have already been triaged by AI,
and we find that organizations that adopt
this, um, are able to resolve 70%
of static analysis tool, uh, security scan
issues automatically with them,
and we'll talk about more details of how, how that was achieved.
There's also the test writing.
Many of us, uh,
know tests are important,
but as individual engineers aren't super excited
to write them ourselves, at least speaking in my own
experience, uh, but we're finding that
agents are both
transformative for helping improve
test coverage
and also really benefit
from having better test coverage in organization.
If I were to describe
one of the underlying best practices
for working with AI
inside your code base productively, it's making
sure the feedback loops are tight.
So how do we know that when this AI generated change
is created,
it's actually gonna work
and one of the best ways to do that is with test coverage, you know, unit
tests, and integration tests and things in the middle as well.
Um, what we found is that, uh,
if you have systematically
under, uh, kind of
lower test coverage in sections or large swaths of
your code repositories than you want, you can do
one-time pushes to go improve test coverage
and make sure you're really monitoring the desired
behavior of the existing system.
And then once you have that in place, it unlocks
further velocity gains from AI on every other use
case on top.
It's important that we're not just talking about the
product capabilities that are needed to be successful, but also
what's actually needed from the enterprise
to roll these out in a productive way, and we
have seen many of these rollouts with
varying levels of velocity and success,
and I just wanna share a few best practices that we've seen,
um, for asynchronous agents
in particular, but coding agents in
general. The first is
that this new generation of tools
um represent more of a workflow transformation
than a a new type of developer tool
it's co-worker not co-pilot
and so because of that um.
This is a big, this is a big workflow change. It's
also a new skill
for engineers to learn inside an organization.
We've actually found that people who are already engineering
managers
are sometimes the most productive contributors
with this next generation of tools because they're already good at
delegating.
And so this is something that everyone is going to benefit
from at some point in the future, being able to work
as an individual contributor itself but also delegate
productively to AI.
And having internal teams that
sort of lead the charge on this front become
a center of excellence
for the overall
organization. Is really, really helpful
to making sure that others can kind of learn
from these best practices.
And the most effective rollouts, they
tend to combine.
The top down mandate
with the bottoms up buying,
especially a large enterprise scale,
you will have a wide range of
engineering, uh, of engineering buy-in from
people chomping at the bit to use the las and grace AI
tools to people who say I have done
coding the way I've done it for 30 years and I am
not changing,
um, and we found that, um, you know, both
approaches are gonna be present and are gonna be important
for the future of productivity inside
the enterprise.
But the way to move the needle forward
is to just celebrate the wins and make sure
that there are folks who are getting
success, uh, that that's highlighted, that's emphasized,
and other people can learn from that.
Uh, we've seen even the most grizzled skeptics,
uh, discover a use case. That they thought
was impossible with AI
and completely turn around and become an evangelist,
but it requires this sort of social cohesion
and organizational buy-in,
you know, tactically we've seen everything from
people adding line items in the performance
review rubric about AI utilization
to doing specific all hands or
um highlights of the best uses of AI that are
discovered
inside the team.
The second is that the setup and the integration
is actually really tricky and it's also
critical.
Um, agents are going to be
onboarded more like human engineers
than like dev tools over time.
Again, the best gains come from the
entire software development life cycle automation, not
just one piece,
and to do that actually well,
you need access to the same tools and systems
that a human engineer would use to do their work.
So every Devon session it's configured
in a virtual machine that has an identical
development environment to the human engineer's virtual
machine, but if Devin doesn't have access to
the same tools the human engineer would use to check
their work,
then the productivity gains are going to be capped.
And a particular pitfall to avoid
is the the partial access
rollout trap where you've
approved an exciting new tool, you're ready to roll
it out, but you've only, you've only done it
for the source code and actually for engineers
to be proactive in your systems, they also need to
run the internal, the internal test suite.
Uh, they need to run some internal tools. Um,
if you don't have those as well, you're leaving significant
amounts of autonomy on the table. Um,
Imagine coding yourself without being able to
run or test your code. It would be very hard.
So this is, this is a critical thing, uh,
to get right.
The second is that, uh, you know, how you
actually instruct these AI agents,
it's a skill. It's not, it's not something that
everyone inherently picks up, kind of like
how you delegate tasks to, uh,
coworkers or to reports on your team.
If we've seen
prompts that are one line and
extremely vague to build an entire end
to end system from scratch that have very low probability
of success, and we started to build in
coaching and tooling in our own systems
to help people learn how to work better with AI systems
and in some cases automate the prompt creation
process entirely.
If you are going from a Jira ticket, which is often
underscoped,
we found that rather than just copy and
pasting that Jira ticket into an agentic
AI system like Devon.
That if you assign that ticket to Devin,
we will first do a detailed scoping
deep dive where Devin will research every aspect
of your code base,
understand what's all the relevant context for this
particular ambiguous ticket,
and then it will construct a prompt for itself. It's
much more detailed. It says these are the best practices.
Here's what exactly what we need to do, um, here's
how you can test your own work,
and this type of metap prompting is becoming
increasingly popular.
The next is that uh
training
because of this complexity,
the gains to training are actually really high.
So if you imagine we all know that some engineers
have dramatically higher impact on the organization
than other engineers,
we think that that gap is going to actually widen
with AI. Everyone's, uh, everyone's baseline
moves up, but the best performers
can become even more leveraged than
before and as an extreme example,
you can imagine.
Really proactive individual engineers in
your organization
almost becoming like
CTOs of an entire
army of AI agents. That's the
direction that software engineering is going,
uh, and so getting folks, the
helping folks reach their, the closer to the
ceiling of productivity gains can have like a multiplicative
benefit, um, and there should
be time for people to actually play and learn with these tools and
best prac and knowledge sharing best practice the same
way that we, you know, we help each other learn, learn
coding. The second is, and
the the last, and this is very important,
is like how do we actually measure this stuff,
um, so metrics and measurement
is one of the most talked about parts of AI software
engineering. It's quite challenging for a lot of folks
and um there's many different approaches for how to
do this,
um, on one end of the spectrum you
can have really granular input metrics,
probably the worst one being number of lines
of code written by AI.
On the other end of the spectrum you have complete end to end
business outcomes.
Great, we have saved 10 many billions of dollars
or
made 10 many billions of dollars from AI
progress and we've shipped at this much higher
velocity.
The way we think about it is that it makes sense to take metrics
at multiple levels of abstraction, but
over time
the higher impact metrics are closer
to the end to end
outcome-based metrics. Um, uh, that's
really what matters. And so
when we're seeing successful
AI software engineering agent rollouts
in large enterprises,
most often this is measured
on specific project timelines,
shrinking dramatically and requiring
much fewer engineering resources.
And the enterprises we work with, um,
almost always reinvest those
engineering resources into more projects because
the demand for code is sort of insatiable
and so people are shipping more and more and more migrations
that maybe wouldn't have gotten done because they were infeasible before
are now happening and they're happening quickly.
So the ideal is measure the wall clock
time of large scale projects. It's
gonna take 2 years now it's gonna take 6 months. It
was gonna take 1000 engineers, now it takes 100.
That's the, that's the sort of the gold standard.
Uh, one below that is
how much human time you're
actually saving on a per unit of work basis.
This is another huge benefit
of applying AI software engineering for the
entire SDLC.
If you take a Jira ticket and you're assigned to an agent
and that agent solves it end to end, you
now know how many story points, uh, were
done autonomously by AI,
and you have some accountability metric of that would
have taken this much human engineering time and
that's worth this much to me, and the ROI is very easy to
do. Absent that, uh,
you look at the velocity of teams, uh,
you know, what's the merge PR rate? Are the number of merged PRs
going up? Um, are we able to
get more, uh, to have more smaller
teams
outputting the same amount per team?
This is how you actually capture the productivity gains
of AI in a way that's deployable and paralyzable
as opposed to kind of survey-based and
anecdotal.
Um, I wanted to talk about what
this looks like end to end in the real world
at large enterprise scale,
and, and the customer I'm excited to share,
uh, the details about how they did this successfully is ITA.
ITA is the largest bank in Latin America.
They're a global financial scale and
very high complexity. They have $0.5 trillion
in assets, over 70 million
customers. They operate across 18 countries,
and they have one of the largest engineering organizations
is all of Latin America, over 17,000 people
working in technology.
First, I want to talk about their results, and then we'll talk about how
they achieve them specifically.
Um, ITAO has indexed more than 300,000 lines of code
documented automatically with Devon.
Um, more than 75% of teams spanning
17,000 engineers are using Devon
in production.
70% of all security vulnerabilities flagged
by static code analysis tools are auto-mediated
by Devon today.
They measure on average 5 to 6x
faster modernization and migration end to end
wall clock time for projects.
And they've 2xed their test coverage from less than 50%
to around 90% on
key critical systems.
So these are some of the, these are some of the results
deploying this at scale.
Um,
IAO approached evaluating agents
kind of like working with a new person
on the team.
Eventually you're gonna
start with smaller tasks, build trust, learn
how to work with that person,
and then grow over time.
Um, one squad at Itao used Devon
for everything possible,
uh, that they could, and they ended up, uh, delivering
two releases in 3 months, which was double what they had
originally planned.
Um, and on measurements of code quality
and developer satisfaction they saw significant performance
gains using depth.
In terms of how this helped over time,
uh, just like when you're on boarding a new human engineer,
when you on board a new AI engineer,
day one, you might know, they might know a lot about coding.
Devin might know a lot about coding, but it's not going to know anything
about you. This is the benefit of
rolling out these systems early
with compounding knowledge
under the hood
every day you work with Devin, every interaction you have,
it gets smarter, better, faster
over time. It learns the specific organizational
context that matters to you,
and that makes future PRs more likely to
be successful, more likely to merge, more likely to be
relevant.
Um, this code-based understanding,
uh, is again the, the key starting
point of how these, of how these systems work.
Um, where Ita found this in particularly helpful
was architecture documentation.
Um, this led to 10x faster planning.
Again, many of these large scale real world systems
are written by people who are no longer at the company, uh,
with inadequate documentation. It takes huge
amounts of time
gathering data and information.
Um, uh, one of the product managers
for, uh, for IO named Stefano, he said
that developers at ITO have been excited by how far Devon
can go. We've seen it handle problems we initially
thought were too complex,
especially for teams working across massive codebases where most,
most other products struggle to absorb that amount of context.
And I'll say one interesting side note is that
product managers are some of the biggest beneficiaries of this
new wave of tools because product managers are often
dependent. On engineers to get their questions answered,
but now just like Devin is the first
line triage for static analysis, security
vulnerabilities, Devin can also be the first line
answer triage for questions from tech,
from engineering adjacent functions, uh, like
why ask the engineer when you could first ask,
uh, ask Devin, get an instant answer that's grounded
in the code, and that's been a killer use case for
product managers,
um. In terms of
writing code,
one of my favorite use cases that HO, uh,
deployed Debbonet is what's called the
CNPJ Compliance Project.
Uh, so Brazil
has, like the US,
taxpayer numbers for companies.
Uh, unlike the US,
Brazil's numbers for, uh, taxpayer numbers
for companies used to be numbers, and
a new regulation was passed,
so they're now going to be alphanumeric.
This is basically the Y2K catastrophe
of Brazil.
Uh, every enterprise in all of Brazil is scrambling
to become compliant with this new thing,
and this is affecting
really large scale production systems that have been around
for decades, uh, including
significant cobalt infrastructure Eito
that's mission critical
to be, um, to kind of maintain performance and
compliance.
Um, Devin was able to do end to end
migration for CMPJ compliance
across all repos at EIO that were tested.
Um, one example was a SQL Server migration that
covered 800 database objects that,
uh, leveraged stored procedures and kind of legacy
practices, uh, and they were able to get
this to compliance to completion with modern CMPJ
regulation over 5x faster than was
budgeted. Again, large scale projects that you can
break up into simple work. This is the recipe.
And ultimately what we're seeing is
that you know CIOs are expected
to get more done,
and AI leverage is the best way to
do it. Uh, the, the CTO of Vito said
that speed is the ultimate competitive advantage.
Uh, AI is the critical enabler that allows
us to dramatically accelerate the ability to
respond to customer needs,
um, and this is a key part of their strategy
and their success.
Uh, with that, thanks so much for joining and happy
to answer questions from anyone in the audience.
Thank you.